les maisons des années 1950
durant les années 1950 quelques riches
familles de la réunion font bâtir des
maisons modernes dont l'architecturé voc
avec un léger décalage le style des
années 1930 940 en europe l'une des
première d'entre elles la maison
ricquebourg se trouve à saint denis
l'architecte jean albany à remplacer la
façade en bois d'une vieille maison par
une façade en maçonnerie de style art
déco
il a également construit sur la
chaussée-royale à saint-paul
l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre de cette époque
commandé par roger cerveau maire de la
ville dans les années 60
cette imposante maison évoque l'
architecture des manhwas le soin
particulier apporté au traitement des
façades lors de la construction et mises
en valeur par le travail des peintres
réalisés lors des récentes rénovations
ce chantier a également conduit au
remplacement des bardeaux du toit par du
zaï propriété de la commune
cette ancienne maison particulière qui
accueille aujourd'hui le service
culturel de la ville dispose également
d'un lieu d'exposition principalement
dédié à la photographie
situé rue de paris la maison fenice la
plus atypique de tout
reprenons le vocabulaire architectural
de mallet stevens l'architecte mauricien
jacques démarrer la dessine en 1954
ces grandes maisons aspirer des années
30 sont bientôt remplacées par des
constructions en béton plus moderne et
plus stéréotypé